welcome back to new rockstars we finally
have a trailer for moonlight and it was
the scariest [ __ ] like what's up with
all the old ladies being so scary in the
mcu like they're so scary that captain
marvel had to beat one down on a bus on
public transportation someone has to
stop he's geriatric menaces this is
rogue theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for their nerdy titles
that we love my name is mt and going
rogue with me today is someone always
willing to embrace the chaos it's
jessica clements hello joseph hi i'm
very geriatric
hey me too honestly i'm as geriatric
honestly i'm as geriatric as they come
this is a real fact i have a like a
metal rod several metal rods in my foot
um because what a surgery that i've
undergone yes i am
that's actually true so i have a robot
foot i'm cyborg holy [ __ ] that's amazing
sad cyborg
you get in those body mods from boba
fett
getting those boba fett bodybots
thundercats just working in the squad
why did they even sew you up you know
why why sew it up and hide all that
beautiful beautiful
inner piping exactly yes exactly
and also someone always ready to be the
fist of gonshu it's whitney then
laningham whitney what's going on girl
oh man not not a whole lot i i'm now
just picturing the inside of your foot
[Laughter]
i mean most people do when i uh when i
tell them that fact it's really timely
yeah normal and finally a man that
always looks good dressed in white it's
tommy bechdol what's going on tommy i
wanna a big head gang my peaches and
cream gang shout out to everybody
shower gang never baths we invented that
the other day i want to let everybody
know that when mt says i look good
dressed in white he's referring to my
wedding day and not any meetings that i
would go to with fellow white men
dressed in all white okay so that's a
very dicey oh no
it's a good distinction to me yes yes
it's a virginal white not a hateful
white okay because i am pure as the
driven snow i am very i'm very pure uh
i've never kissed i've never kissed a
girl before but i have kissed a doll
so let's go
what the [ __ ] hey
you know what that's what me and you
have in common tommy wait a minute
what's that i don't even know never been
kissed anyway all right let's go back to
you've kissed a doll what kind of a doll
was it yes so i did some sort of weird
voodoo as a kid where i would kiss dolls
and see if it would come true in real
life so i you know i kissed spider-man i
kissed a barbie i kissed wonder woman i
was real bisexual with my doll kissing
anyways
kissing kissing dolls left oh yeah i was
in toys r us just kissing every doll's
band for life from toys r us band for
life from kb toys band for life
from target band for life from from from
walmart you know i took kmart out of
business why do you think you don't see
kmarts anymore because you couldn't stop
kissing that's right too much kissing
not enough kissing wishing
[Music]
so anyway what do we want to talk about
today guys
the editors are going to be like how
much of that do we leave in i say 100
stays in
it's what moon knight would want and
there's our segway back into the game
hey
perfect segue so guys we finally got our
first look at moon knight in the trailer
that was released on monday and there
was a lot to take away from this trailer
but one of the most interesting things
was related to ethan hawke's character
so it leads us to our first topic of the
day what is the cult in moon knight all
about because in that recently released
moon knight trailer we got our first
look at ethan hogg's character arthur
harrow and he appears to be the leader
of some type of cult and from his
monotone cultist leader getup to a
throng of people just kneeling before
him in the street we're led to believe
that he's in charge of something
mysterious and possibly really dangerous
in a world that's been rocked by the
blip and the recent emergence of a giant
celestial in the middle of the indian
ocean what could this cult possibly be
about what do you guys think
oh
i can go first okay jess what you got
girl so i say this a lot and i'll say it
again i think in trailers uh marvel
really likes to shift our views what
we're seeing is not what we're really
seeing so i think ultimately the god
which i could be pronouncing this wrong
please don't kill me for this khan shu
yeah you got it you got it not only did
he in the comics like take over the mind
of moon knight um i think that's kind of
what's happening here where we're all
seen within the mind of moon knight
because in the 2015 issues with jeff
lemire i think when it was like a
psychotic run of like all this mindless
shambling where it's like is it d.i.d or
is his brain just colonized by a god so
i think that we're seeing inside of his
mind where
konshu is in there posing as doctor or
author harrow as ethan hawk's character
because he's also known to take over and
look as a person just to talk to other
people he doesn't have to show himself
as a god all the time he can show
himself as just a normal person so i
think he's controlling arthur harrow in
the mind of moon knight and that's the
visuals that we see is we think it's his
consciousness kind of like inception
where it's like don't attract attention
because everyone's gonna start looking
to us it's like we're inside your mind
moon knight but i'm the one running the
show the god and that's why everyone in
here is following my tasks and not yours
so i don't think it's necessarily a cult
more than is just mindless people in the
mind of moon knight and even if it was a
cult it could be a cult for konshu the
god there you go i'm true a
philosophical major so like are you
saying like fight club types of vibes or
like yeah yes it's in his mind it's in
his mind but imagine the actual
underground ring of fight club where
they're fighting is also within the mind
of uh not brad pitt
edward norton
well they're both tyler it doesn't
matter but yeah
yeah
i think it's within edward norton's mind
so just like all of that is within moon
knight's mind because he is
going through a lot of mental illness yo
if you've ever read a moon knight comic
it is one of the most confusing
experiences of all time so like
something like this is highly probable
even though it sounds super rogue it's
highly probable it's so good i don't
want to give like a shout out to um
warren ellis but the comic that warren
ellis did do
really sums up everything within the
first volume in like the first five
pages uh everything there is about moon
knight that you're like this is a little
too crazy you can puzzle together in his
issues uh but i again worn elvis also
has a problematic pass so oh man but
that's a really great theory i love that
theory it's a super rogue what else you
guys got i can go next uh so
the direction i took it in is kind of uh
what i think the mcu in t
and the mcu tv shows kind of like to do
which is take from the comics but kind
of reform them kind of shift them around
so that there are kind of touchstones
from the books but you know names and
phrases and characters but they're
they're somewhat presented differently
so in the comics arthur harrow is a uh
is a brilliant scientist who suffers
from a painful neurological condition
and he uses uh his experiments to try to
to heal that condition in himself
eventually leading to his kind of
dismissal from the mainstream scientific
world and over to this like kind of
shadow think tank called omnium i think
that what the end this show is going to
do is make the cult named omnium there
is precedent in the real world with
nexium being occult so omnium does kind
of sound like a modern day cult name and
i believe that all of the people that
are
kneeling down to him are our worshipers
but also patients of this health-driven
cult who suffer from chronic pain or
mental illness therefore making moon
knight uh the perfect recruitee someone
with disassociated personal disorder
personality disorder would be the
perfect person to join that cult and
almost be a right-hand man for arthur
harrow so i see him as a cult leader
that is leading with what most cults
promise which is a better life and you
know a happier life and a more
fulfilling life so he's telling these
people that he's going to heal them but
what he's really doing is experimenting
on them and using them as pawns for a
criminal agenda interesting beautiful
very very interesting okay okay i would
have never thought about that this is
why i love your big head
that's why i live this is why you're
part of the big head gang this happens
right now the threads are screaming on
this
this head this headband is actually as
round as like a giant dinner plate but
it just looks like a normal-sized
headband around my huge head oh the
elastic has just completely worn off
there's no elastic this is glued to my
head right now
oh baby
oh honey oh my god oh sweet
if we remove it your brains just spill
out yeah they just sleep out yes my
brains are all liquid anyway at this
point uh-huh really
anyway whitney
what you got girl yeah okay so i have
kind of combo theories um i definitely
hard agree with tommy because after i
reread that comic it just seems really
plausible that he is going to be this
cult leader who's uh using his followers
in order to like experiment on them in
the comics he has like a um like a
neurological disorder that like locks up
his jaw and causes like extreme pain in
his face and we don't see that same
thing going on
in the trailer so i'm wondering if it is
gonna be a different kind of disorder
that he possibly has and that his
supporters possibly have um i don't know
if they're gonna go completely comic
book accurate with that but it was like
a main part of his character was that
his face is kind of uh messed up in the
comics this dude also ended up becoming
a hardcore nazi in the comics
and if there's one thing i know about
nazis it's that
boys in museums love to fight them we've
got indiana jones and now coming up
we've got moon knight and i'm like he
works in a museum he could fight a nazi
i could see that happening so i either
think that he is going to be performing
these like
maybe not nazi because obviously in the
mcu we have hydra already and stuff like
that but i do think that he is going to
be performing these experiments he's
using
you know quote unquote outcasts from
society so disabled or mentally ill or
whatever it might be disenfranchised
people i think he's going to be
using them as his test subjects yes but
my combo theory is that i
do think that the cult itself is gonna
be about something else like their
beliefs
are going to have to either be
based in like the egyptian culture and i
think it's going to have to do with all
of these events that happened after the
blip because people are losing their
minds a gigantic celestial just appeared
on the side of the entire planet and i
think that people are going to be
looking for faith for those answers i
think that he is going to be
manipulating those types of people who
do need something to believe in and he's
like why not egypt ah here you go
people
sounds fun why not those guys let's take
it back to the olden times baby we don't
need all these modern gods we don't need
airships things were so much better way
back then way better yeah those were so
much better back in the day
remember
why can't we all just kick it old
testament i want to sacrifice my son i
want a giant flood i want to do all of
that i want to take my boy up to the top
of a mountain and threaten to slit his
bro before god says
don't do it i was just going to do it
i was jk i was jk i just wanted to
really do it that was that was just for
the laws guys that was just for the laws
you know me i'm god and i like to party
it's like yo gabriel you bet me twenty
dollars you wouldn't do it
i just lost that dude
god and gabriel were the original
impractical jokers
don't hate on the impractical jokers
i'm going to hate on the impractical
jokers yes
these are all amazing theories but i
gotta give the the main rogue point to
jess because yeah it was super rogue
and it was just super i just i just dig
it i dig it a lot i dig your brain just
even though you're not officially part
of the big head gang i have a small baby
head and i love it and i'm proud of it
you have a beautiful head no need to
make any comments about it okay even
though i just did and referring to it as
beautiful i've never really thought
about my head before but i guess i have
one whitney you have you have a head as
well and i will not i have one it exists
and i think and i'm thankful that it's
here i just want to give up some big
head gratitude head gratitude today
thank you everyone thank you oh wait
tommy quick question for you though so
what do you think that that like the
culti acronym is going to stand for
because in the comics they don't ever
tell you what it stands
oh omniscient
neurological
inclusive uniting i'm neat i already
spelled it wrong didn't it no i'm
already sold i'm already sold come on
wait i'm sold on uh omniscient magical
neurological
inclusive
uniting
mysticism
this sounds like scientology
you down with omni um oh yeah yum yum
i'm out okay that's the first thing you
see when you go on the website my other
complaint though about arthur harrow is
that if he's really basing his [ __ ] on
david koresh
get get sunglasses man you can't do it
without the creepy sunglasses the creepy
sunglasses is like half the thing yeah
hey if he actually ends up being the sun
king
maybe yeah and he needs it and he needs
them maybe he needs them i don't know my
two cents about what this whole cult
thing is about is i think that the whole
crocodile aspect of the trailers is a
big hint as to what's going on because
sobek in the comics is this crocodile
god and is an actual egyptian god in
real life and i think that what's
happening here is that arthur harrow is
slowly becoming the sun king and they're
they're mixing up the characters oh
what if it was just alligator loki
calling on himself exactly he just like
zips up he's just checking in
that's my rogue theory alligator loki is
gonna be the crocodile god yeah no
alligator loki and mark spector text
regularly that's my theory aren't they
actually called something in egyptian
lore the crocodile god has a name hold
on king k rool
shut the [ __ ] up
thank you so much historically sobek is
tied to the uh egyptian god ra
so like there's actually like a sobek
raw hybrid in like egyptian mythology so
um yeah i think that he's slowly
becoming the sun king and we're gonna
see this like crocodile sun king god on
a more serious note uh we here at new
rockstars just wanted to take a quick
moment to acknowledge the passing of
actor gaspard uliel this week uh he had
a role on moon night and we can't wait
to see the great work that he does on
there and we are all super deeply
saddened by the news and we all just
wanted to send our condolences to his
family and friends but up next we're
going to talk about that really
interesting accent oscar isaac is using
but first check out the book of boba
fett inspired shirt over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
it's a really cool design that you'll
see eric wearing on our weekly wikileaks
show with our boy tommy buying our merch
is a great way to support this channel
while also looking like a real stylish
nerd so check it out over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
and of course this winter upgrade your
daily routine with bespoke post and
their seasonal lineup of must-have box
of awesome collections bespoke post
partners with small businesses and
emerging brands to bring you unique
goods every month we've gotten some
really great cooking and skin care
products from bespoke post in the past
and no matter what you're into box of
awesome has you covered from winter
cocktails to cozy threads and camping
gear essentials box of awesome has
collections for every part of your life
their new scorch box which has hot
sauces from all over the country has got
me sweating just thinking about it so to
get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com to help them pick the right
box of awesome for you and they release
new boxes every month so things are
changing things are dynamic just like
life so it's free to sign up and you can
skip a month or cancel anytime each box
costs only 45 bucks but has over 70
dollars worth of gear inside plus with
each box of awesome you're supporting
small businesses which is dope so get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com and enter code
rogue at checkout that box of
awesome.com code rogue for 20 off your
first box and of course lots of folks
have a resolution to learn a new
language and our friends at babel are
here to help you succeed it is the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions a few new
rockstar staffers are learning spanish
with babel the battle process is
addictively fun fast and easy babel
teaches bite-sized language lessons for
real-world use it's as easy as opening
an app on your phone and babbles
15-minute lessons makes it the perfect
way to learn a new language on the go
babel lessons were created by over 100
language experts that's a team choose
from over 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german and babel's speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent there are so
many ways to learn with babble in
addition to lessons you can access
podcasts games videos stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20-day
money-back guarantee so start your new
language learning journey today with
babel right now when you purchase a
three-month battle subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use promo code
rogue that's
[Music]
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com code rogue babble
language for life learn all the
languages so you can talk to everybody
and make lots of friends and hey this is
a great month to be a fan of thrilling
and scary stuff because shutter is
releasing some killer content with
shutter you can stream supernatural
thriller and horror movies and tv shows
across all your favorite devices shutter
streaming library has everything from
original movies like vhs 94 and pg
psycho gorman to the hit series creep
show by executive producer greg nigtero
of the walking dead they have a bunch of
creepy classics like the wicker man and
halloween and a bunch of foreign films
and smaller flicks you probably missed
and we've had multiple arguments in the
office about the movie the invitation
which you can stream on shutter you
should watch it to have some arguments
of your own because arguing is fun and
shutter has just released an exclusive
documentary called woodlands dark and
days bewitched it's the ultimate history
of the folk horror genre so stream all
of this and more from shutters ever
growing library ad free for just 5.99 a
month that's kind of ridiculous so if
you're a fan of supernatural thriller
and all things horror you're going to
love shutter as much as i do and right
now you can stream your first 30 days of
shutter for free so go to shutter.com
and use code rogue that is
s-h-u-d-d-e-r.com
code rogue to stream your first 30 days
of shutter for free shutter.com code
rogue shutter get your pants scared off
your legs get your pants scared off your
legs off your legs moving on another
thing that we noticed in the moonlight
trailer was the interesting accent oscar
isaac was using is oscar isaac's weird
accent intentional for most of the
moonlight trailer oscar isaac speaks
with a very heavy british accent and
goes by the name steven so what's up
with that accent is this an intentional
choice by the character or is he not
even aware that this persona speaks with
an accent i mean it's
both
yeah right
yeah right so if we are sticking to the
whole that he might or he does have did
dissociative identity disorder um and he
has that those characters he has mark he
has jake
and he has himself right now and then he
has moon knight um then i think
that character stephen yes steven
stephen is the one that's going to be
speaking in a british accent um i think
it's clear that he's gonna be [ __ ]
fluctuating between the identities
because in the trailer what i really
liked was that scene with him in the car
um in the truck and he's just like holy
[ __ ] i have a gun out of nowhere it's
like yeah you're waking
[Laughter]
[Music]
honestly though like if i woke up
holding a gun in a van full of cupcakes
i'd i that sounds fine you're like makes
sense yeah that's a trap that's a good
consolation prize for your shop sounds
like something i would get into
so i think that and the fact that um it
looks like in that scene um who i assume
is playing frenchy
right the guy
he is dressed up in the same garb as
ethan hawk's character is when he's
getting praised and he's in shackles so
i think they both got out of an
institution um whether they escaped or
they jumped out but in that institution
he was a different character than
stephen is so i think that character got
out they're on the race and he's just
like what the hell i like also in one of
the comics they mention that time
doesn't matter where they're at that you
can live in present and past so they
were like you can be born in one minute
and then wake up in another because they
just keep [ __ ] with time so i think
that's a matter of him time hopping or
time jumping or just showing up because
we need to remember that
if my theory is correct of that he is
going through something he has either
like the d.i.d or again the god is
taking over his mind and can make him do
whatever is happening and awake at any
weird time well jessica this just proves
men would rather wake up in a truck full
of cupcakes and guns then go to therapy
it's true i'm tired of it it is so true
men would rather shackle one ankle to
this to a bed
to a ring of sand than just go to
therapy he's like i need to put the sand
out here does anybody else think that
there's like a better way to keep
yourself in bed than that i just don't i
don't know about the one ankle yeah like
okay like for example like did you guys
ever watch mike birbaglia's
uh yeah sleep walk with me yeah yeah
yeah so like that like why couldn't moon
knight just get himself like a
microbiglia esque sleeping bag
real tight i feel like that become fear
i think he's so hot i can't get out of
it i can't get out of this yeah like
maybe he has a blanket problem i don't
know but i think that he should watch
sleepwalk with me i think that moon
knight would take a lot away i actually
know a german woman named deeda who will
make sure that you don't leave the bed
unless you say a very specific
combination of words
i think i also you know you know
i know yeah she's bi-coastal she'll go
she goes to she goes she goes the east
coast west coast yeah but last time i
checked she doesn't have just the one
ankle shackle that's true yeah she's got
lots of she's got tons of shadows got a
few oh god overall that's with that
included that is my so i count i get
those points too if i win yes yes
that was my idea
absolutely okay i like that that's
really interesting what do you guys got
well so steven grant is like a
it's like first in the comics like a
child that he thinks he meets right like
he he has him as an entirely different
personality i think like where it's it's
uh it's moonlight
seeing that like this this little kid i
think there are going to be
other actors cast as the different
personalities through oscar isaac's
vision so like when he's being this
goofy british guy i think it's going to
cut back and forth between oscar isaac
and then who oscar isaac thinks he is in
that moment so in my opinion the reason
that they're starting off with the
goofiest one is because it's going to
get like most of these mcu shows uh more
and more serious as the shows go on by
the last episode it's gonna be mark
spector fighting and being like full-on
moon knight which is you know are also
an unhinged character but i believe they
i think they're starting off with the
british accent because it's silly and
kind of can get people into the
unhingedness of the character
i can't remember which one but one of
them is also like a taxi driver so i
think this one is more fun
there's a little girl i think there's an
astronaut there's a bunch there's an
astronaut yeah there's something i think
it's interesting that we've only seen
mark and uh steven and the trailer so
far and we haven't yeah there is no jake
lockley which which a couple people have
been like hey where's that at unless
that's what they're trying to do which
makes sense
this is such a i'm actually impressed by
how much they can put down in this
trailer because there's so much to moon
night after rereading the comics that i
was like there's too much to put into a
movie so i'm glad they put into a series
but it's still too much to put into a
series and also do you really want to
like it is very important to touch on
did but you need to do it in a right way
and it's really like a line that you can
do completely wrong and so to a touch
this subject which i'm really happy
about i loved what they did with like
green goblin and um and spider-man i was
like this is great this is perfect i
love that you guys came kind of
took it to a different level so it's
like this is a project that's already
really hard to try to like convey and
they're doing it so maybe they're just
like we're gonna have two just two just
two personalities just two no more like
yeah maybe they're shorter
that makes sense to me i think that
makes sense i think it makes sense
because like this is like season one of
what i'm assuming to be a multiple
season you know we're gonna get more
entries of moon night and so like to
slowly introduce the personalities to
moon knight as as he goes on and as we
learn more about him it's just super
interesting because like oscar isaac is
an incredible actor so like we're gonna
like slowly be introduced to these new
people it's like oh man this is just
like a new performance this is like a
new version of the character almost so
like i think that's a very smart
decision i think they should just be
oscar isaac movie characters like one of
his personalities should be lou and
davis one should be poe dameron one
should be poe dameron
i would i would [ __ ] with that i have
this weird feeling that like he could be
just cycling through his multiverse
personalities okay okay okay mt mt
you're correct i think you're on to
something i was thinking about that i
was thinking about that because i was
also like are we getting into the
multiverse are we getting into gods
because i don't ever get like into
eternals are we getting into doctor
strange and so i was trying so hard
because they're opening so many portals
to different space egypts that i was
like is this god's or is this not like
is this
and so i can't put my freaking i guess
we just gotta wait till it shows up
because this could there's an issue
where they fight nightmare like i was
like what are we gonna do like where is
this going i have no idea so i hope
you're right i hope you're right i hope
it's not but no like with all this
egyptian stuff with gods like i just
can't imagine apocalypse not having a
cameo in moonlight with oscar isaac just
chilling
like oh well like from the ashes of the
world we'll build a better one just
randomly just saying that because like
people will freak out because like
that's a multiverse nod to the the x-men
film but yeah what you got wendy oh um
when i heard
the trailer and like that specific line
that you guys were talking about where
he's like a cartel if it's a dream or
real life like that yours is better than
his yours is better than yes
i was kind of wondering like if the way
that because like it's it's that like
his voice sounds weirder when he's
saying that particular line than when he
says any of his other little lines in
his accent and so i was wondering if
that was because it's another
like chopped up line like maybe there's
more to the line you know like what they
did with no way home where they like
kind of like chopped up dr strange's
stuff and they mixed it around i think
that that's probably the line but i'm
wondering if there's more that comes
after or more before that that would
give us better context and who he's like
saying it too yeah yeah like who he's
saying it to and like what the deal is i
think that that's kind of what i'm
waiting for they're all really great
theories so i'm going to give everybody
the rogue point because this is all
fantastic and like you don't want to
really knows what like i have this weird
feeling
that this steven grant guy just has no
recollection obviously of mark spector
about
who he actually is and it is so
interesting that his main persona isn't
his main persona like what they've shown
us so far like he doesn't learn about
his main persona until he finds that
weird
flip phone
what are they called razors he finds a
razor he finds a razor
[Laughter]
but yeah no i really do wonder how his
steven grant persona is going to feel
about not being real i think that's like
super interesting to explore yeah i love
all these theories but now we must move
on to
our rogue question you guys ready for
this one oh yeah
oh yeah so tom cruise wants to film
movies in space and some producers he's
working with even want to attach a
production studio to the international
space station people have so much money
good god i'm struggling pitch me your
rogues ideas for which cosmic character
tom cruise should play in the mcu
none of them none of them please don't
i'm gonna go rogue and say absolutely
[ __ ] this idea how about tom cruise take
some of his
space production money to the streets or
farmlands of this nation where there are
children starving and gives them that
money and he can make a film about that
a documentary called how i made the
right decision to stop trying to [ __ ]
make movies in space and started feeding
the hungry yeah which is more like i'm
sorry he's i know he's looking for xenu
up there and i'm always hoping xeno's
gonna bless him that's the only reason
he's going that was what i was going to
say i don't trust him i think he's only
going to space because he thinks he's
reached the final
stage or whatever the [ __ ] and i think
he's going up there for scientology paid
for by scientology and the interest of
learning more for his people
joe if he brings john travolta it's over
for earth like you know that it's over
for earth i think that if rich people
want to film movies in space they
shouldn't be able to film movies on
earth then you gotta pick one and i have
to be like
that's a good qualifier i hate to be a i
hate to be a buzz skill because i know
it's like oh come on exploring space is
like you know it's it's it's the
evolution of people
scientific discoveries and stuff but
let's fix [ __ ] here first before we
start making movies in space like what's
next amusement parks in space we gotta
fix six flights magic mountains first
okay we can't make a movie in space
you're not allowed to ever set foot in
burbank again oh my god
you're banned from burbank yeah
what were you i'm sorry
you know what this isn't really fun
though and i know that that's what so
let me give a serious answer he should
play uh howard the duck and he should
not get to go to space he should have to
only provide the voice well a puppeteer
uh some sort of middle-class puppeteer
working for the jim henson company
puppets the howard the duck puppet while
tom cruise sits in the church of
scientology celebrity center on franklin
avenue voicing uh voicing howard the
duck sorry seth green you you you
deserve it more but tom's got more money
and influence so that's what i say tom
should voice howard the duck
okay tom cruise having the duck all
right well what else we got well i want
to first say i'm giving if i win i want
to give my points to whitney for her
last answer because it was very funny
and also very real
that's true i think it's true i know it
was a sad note but it's very valid i
want people to know where i stand and
it's with whitney about sending people
like him into space but i i for the
funny joke wise i don't want him to play
anything but if he did really have to
put his hands in something and do
something i think they should do another
play version and he plays the grand
master
oh
jeffy that's fun
it will be a little cameo a little cameo
he could do it up and he could do it up
in a fake uh asgard that they build on
the international space station sound
stages yeah i think you should let's
play yeah tree the giant because i think
it'd just be fun that would be a fun
role tom cruise is a tidy person in
general anyway okay but i have an answer
okay i haven't i have an answer i want
tom cruise to reprise his role as the
vampire lestat but in
space in the blade movies so he's gonna
be a vampire blade's gonna be a vampire
and they're gonna fight on the [ __ ]
moon yes that's what i think god
oh my god i like this a lot you know
what i'm going to say that everybody is
a winner because all these ideas are
really good i know i always do this but
like i just don't like choosing one
winner because i love all of you i do
you guys are so smart well jessica wins
because she got the first point so
jessica gets three and win yeah you know
what jessica wins he has the only point
so far so it's true it's the only point
i've awarded just give me the damn
points baby
all right
but we're all winners because i love all
of you and everybody watching that is it
for this episode of rogue theory thanks
to our guests jessica clemons whitney
van lenningham and tommy bechtold for
joining us this episode support all of
their stuff but of course support our
channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch at new rockstarsmerch.com
and if you've got thoughts on some of
our rogue theories you can share them on
our discord if you're over 18 search for
a new rockstars discord server and join
the conversation follow me at
mastertainment follow new rockstars on
all social platforms and be sure to
subscribe on our youtube channel here on
youtube thanks again for watching we
love you guys so much and we'll see you
later goodbye happy birthday david lynch
[Music]
you